man that was fast
you remember a couple days ago I gave
you the update on Joe Biden's official
story of his involvement with his son's
foreign business deals
initially years ago Joe said he knew
nothing about hunter's business
then Hunter accidentally admitted that
he and Joe had in fact talked about it
so Joe admitted that he knew about it
but only very little and he said he was
never personally involved
then a couple years ago we started to
see emails and texts from Hunter's
laptop implicating Joe in the business
10 to the big guy that sort of thing
still
Joe maintained he never spoke to any of
those corrupt business guys
then last week we learned from Hunter's
former business partner Devin Archer
that Joe not only spoke with the crooks
but was actually present on more than 20
of the business phone calls so then the
official story I know it's a little
dizzying your head is spinning the
official story became that Biden knew
he discussed it with Hunter he even
spoke with the Crux
but they only talked about the weather
so you know he wasn't actually involved
just uh passing niceties to appease his
son
well
not 48 hours later the story has been
updated again thanks to a letter from
the app were mentioned Hunter crony
Devon Archer this is a letter from Joe
Biden while Joe is vice president to
Devin Archer dated 2011 the letter reads
dear Devin
I apologize for not getting a chance to
talk to you at the luncheon yesterday I
was having trouble getting away
from hosting president who then
president of China I hope I get a chance
to see you again soon with Hunter
I hope you enjoyed the lunch thanks for
coming sincerely and then it signed Joe
Biden P.S this is handwritten happy you
guys are together
so hey Devin Archer I just invited you
to this fancy lunch with the president
of China yeah sorry I didn't get a
chance to publicly chat with you there
but here's a note partially hand written
uh explaining how much I love that
you're doing business with my son
and coming to lunches with the president
of China
look forward to seeing you again soon
with my son
I I'm harsh on Joe Biden but I don't
think I'm unfair to him I try to give
his charitable read as I can how do you
read that as anything other than Joe
Biden's being actively involved with
Hunter's foreign Shakedown business for
now over 10 years
it's a Dozen Years how do you read the
unusual Act of Joe Biden's Vice
President Joe Biden's even sending the
letter to this then 30 something year
old partner of Hunter to say nothing of
the clearly pointed language in the
letter
he's a crook
he's a Shakedown artist the Apple
doesn't fall far from the tree Joe Biden
is the same as his son minus the crack
I'm Michael Knowles it's the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
show we've got the feel-good video of
the day where some immigrant shop
workers in New York City beat a
shoplifter with a stick I will get to
that we'll get to how important this is
politically and why it feels so
satisfying just viscerally well we watch
it first though
we just got to impeach the guy I have
been very slow on calls for impeachment
I don't think impeachment should be
wielded capriciously and arbitrarily I
don't think that we should only impeach
somebody because we've got a political
Advantage I think there's a legal
predicate we've got to hit I think
Prudence has to play a role here I think
Prudence is the most important political
virtue I'm with Aristotle on that point
okay all of that caution said
[Music]
we just got to impeach the guy I don't
know what other evidence of what other
crimes we could possibly get I don't
know how the political situation in this
country could deteriorate anymore
they're trying to put Donald Trump in
prison for over 500 years and
potentially execute him what are we
waiting for and it would appear that a
number of sitting Republican politicians
and leaders agree with this Lauren
bobert has called for it Jim Banks is
called for Nancy mace's flirted the idea
and the great Senator Ted Cruz has
suggested impeaching not just Biden but
some of Biden's top lieutenants too
I believe the house should pursue three
separate impeachments number one
Alejandro mayorkas the Secretary of
Homeland Security I believe they should
impeach him today right now his conduct
has been atrocious it's created the
worst Humanity humanitarian crisis on
our Southern Border in the history of
our nation the second impeachment
inquiry that should should be open in
the house is an impeachment of Merrick
Garland the attorney general and the
reason is simple the IRS whistleblowers
if their testimony is accurate then
attorney general Merrick Garland lied
under oath to Congress in response to
questioning from me and actively engaged
in obstruction of justice both of those
are felonies for which you should be
impeached but third Joe Biden I agree
with speaker McCarthy I think the house
should open an impeachment inquiry the
allegations in that document from the
FBI are the Joe Biden directly received
a five million dollar bribe and got
another bribe for his son hunter in
exchange for favors from the vice
president of the United States if that
is true he should be impeached
simple as that totally agree uh the the
legal predicate is already there you
don't need to take my word for it Ted
Cruz is one of the best lawyers in the
country and one of the sharpest ones out
there and politically he's very Savvy as
well so the the legal basis I think
we're good mayorkas uh has uh conducted
himself terribly in his office and we
have a this horrific humanitarian crisis
down there uh
the Attorney General speaks for himself
and he lied under oath to Ted Cruz and
then Biden we've got a strong evidence
of crimes on the political front then
we need to impeach these people before
they imprison us
Remember When Donald Trump said they're
not indicting me they're indicting you I
think that's a good line that line is
resonating because we know that it's
true no one ever had a problem with
Donald Trump until Donald Trump started
speaking up
for the unheard from men and women of
the United States the deplorables the
irredeemable the people who the uni
party had not represented for a very
long time
and so Donald Trump went from being
feted and celebrated and a a pop culture
star and named and all these rap songs
and admired all of a sudden he became
the worst criminal he was colluding with
the Russians he was colluding with the
ukrainians he's an insurrectionist he's
a terrorist he's a rapist he's a
murderer he's I don't know whatever he's
all is every terrible thing you could
possibly he's a Hitler he's a he's
everything everything bad and evil
they're going to lock him up and
potentially execute him
just according to the latest charges
uh it's not just that they're going
after Trump they're also spying on
Catholic masses it's also that they're
going in and knocking down the doors of
pro-lifers it's also that they're
calling parents domestic terrorists it's
also that they're letting leftist actual
criminals off of the hook violent
criminals off of the hook at a certain
point
Republicans need to grow a spine and
perhaps some other anatomical features
if you're hearing it from me I am as
cautious as it gets when it comes to
these kinds of things then I think the
time has come folks
if the GOP doesn't impeach these people
what's the GOP for the GOP is for what a
lot of us have long feared that it's for
which is to be the junior partner in the
liberal political establishment and to
be the Court Jester in the Kingdom of
liberalism and to put up a pretense of
opposition but always to fold at The
crucial moments now speaking of disorder
in our political system when things go a
little bit wonky you're going to want to
protect your assets you're going to want
to check out Birch gold right now text
Knowles to 98 98 98 we are days away
from the Durbin Accords the greatest
threat the US Dollars Global dominance
in the past 80 years on August 22nd
brics Nations Brazil Russia India China
and South Africa are expected to
announce the launch of a new
international super currency fully
backed by gold or other Commodities this
is part of their long-term plan to
supplant the U.S and the dollar as
cornerstones of the Global Financial
system you can protect your IRA or 401K
from The Fallout from this Landmark
Announcement by diversifying with gold
from Birch gold historically gold has
been a safe haven in times of high
uncertainty which is right now when
currencies fail gold is a safe haven how
much more time does the Dollar have
protect your savings with gold Birch
gold has an A plus rating With Better
Business Bureau thousands of happy
customers text Knowles kwels to 98 98 98
get your free info kit on gold if a
central bank digital currency becomes a
reality it will be nice to have some
gold to depend upon text Knowles Canada
w-l-e-s to 98 98
speaking of world leaders
Justin Trudeau leader of America's top
hat
has just announced that he is separating
from his wife Sophie Gregoire
why do I even mention this story why am
I interested in the marriage of some
foreign leader particularly a foreign
leader that I don't like very much who
has been rumored to be the son of Fidel
Castro but I actually don't think he
really is uh he's only ideologically the
son of Fidel Castro
the reason the story hit me
is because I feel bad for Justin Trudeau
I did not think it was possible to feel
bad for Justin Trudeau this is a guy who
brutally puts down the Ordinary People
of his country shuts them up locks them
in their homes strips them of their
rights attacks the Canadian truckers
promotes suicide promotes
really a form of homicide they call it
assisted suicide or euthanasia maid
medical assistance in dying but it's
just a way to kill the elderly in the
frail and the mentally impaired and the
poor and the homeless he's he's pushing
this around the country such that now
significant portion of Canadians die
this way by the state helping them to
kill themselves a guy puts pushes
radical abortion laws he's just he's
awful he's he's as bad a leader As It
Gets
and divorce is so terrible
that I still feel bad for him
my interest here is not in Justin
Trudeau it's in divorce divorce is so
bad and we just don't talk about it
enough we focus on the abortion issue
rightly so it's life or death we focus
on some of the radical sexual ideologies
that have permeated the country but we
don't talk very much about a part of
that that is I think
a major
symptom but but also driver of the
sexual Revolution which is divorce it's
just so awful divorce is so awful not
just because it screws up kids
not just because it usually ruins the
lives of the spouses who split not just
because it's in my view metaphysically
and sacramentally impossible because
what God has joined no man can separate
but because the family is the
fundamental political unit so if you
have divorce
then your whole country is going to
split apart at the seams
it's like cracking the atom the atom is
the is the smallest physical unit and
when you when you crack the atom open
things go kablooey well the same thing's
true in a political order when you crack
open the family
even families that don't function that
well even the families of bad people
like Justin Trudeau it can only hurt it
can only be destructive
and it it is the culmination of a
political process that's been going on
for hundreds of years which is to
separate and compartmentalize
things in our political order so we
separate Church from State we separate
politics from culture we separate
economic considerations from social
considerations we we separate men from
women we separate races and classes and
we just we separate everything
we separate scientific considerations
from philosophical and Theological
considerations we separate law from
morality
all the way down to the point that we
separate husband from wife
and all the way in our in our now in our
sexual ideologies that are that are
becoming prevalent we try to separate
body from Soul it doesn't really work
you know in that one particular ideology
that I'm not allowed to mention on
YouTube I think we know which one I'm
talking about
that
that is so so destructive that I could
even feel bad for Justin Trudeau and so
what's the answer to this well we need
to convince people that marriage really
matters we got to convince people to
stick together and stick it out uh
we also need to make it harder to get
divorced
no fault divorce which was a legal
decision
it was it was a decision by our Elite
political class
it wasn't driven by the people it wasn't
Grassroots it wasn't bottom-up it was
driven by liberal Elites
no fault divorce has been a complete
disaster for the human race and
certainly for our civilization nothing
good has come from it and
it's not it's not even a a possibility
there's no such thing as a no-fault
divorce if you make a vow to stay with
someone forever and then you break that
that one or both of you breaks that vow
somebody is at fault someone's done
something right it's just not possible
it's just a lie to say there's no fault
divorce
and the effects are so they're so
difficult to even put your finger on I
mean I know I'm a millennial so pretty
much all of my friends have parents who
are divorced and they're not even aware
often of how the divorce has affected
them but I have friends who were
perfectly ordinary perfectly fine had
nice life and good behavior parents get
divorced and then just you you see from
that very moment they start to get a
little wacky and they start to go become
resentful and they start to question all
sorts of aspects of their identity and
their relationship to the community into
religion it just it's so subtle it's
like it's like rayon in a house I don't
know it's just this poison that spreads
through Society you're not even aware of
it
it's even difficult to trace back
to the cause
you cannot solve the political problems
in the country without addressing the
the rupture that has occurred within the
fundamental political unit which is the
family and the rupture is called divorce
very sorry for the Trudeau's now
moving on to other world leaders other
young global leaders you know my friend
Vivek ramaswamy running for president
surging in the polls
the bake has an asterisk a question mark
around his candidacy that some people
have written into this show and brought
up some people have asked him about in
interviews and it is that Vivek who is
an anti-work businessman who wrote
woking who campaigns against ESG who
would seem to be one of the most vocal
opponents of the globalist corporatist
liberal Elite
this guy is listed on the world economic
Forum website as a young Global leader
now
I
have known about this for years
I remember I thought about why why is he
listed as a WF guy and I know I know
that it has driven Vivek crazy because
the world economic Forum invited him to
be part of their special elite club the
young global leaders and he said no and
I know he said no and I know he never
participated in it he told them to take
my name off I don't want anything to do
with you guys but they listed him anyway
and so because I have a little
background knowledge here I know that
these attacks on Vivek are silly they're
spurious attacks but
he finally proved it he was finally
exonerated here of this charge because
he got the world economic Forum to
apologize for listing him among their
Elites here's the vague discussion
so it was a particular mystery
when the world economic forum after I
had written against their agenda through
my book woking and otherwise happened to
name me on a list of so-called young
global leaders with other so-called
successful Young Americans and young
people around the world
I rejected their award I declined it I
said that I deeply disagreed with the
values of the world economic forum and
that I wouldn't be a good fit for
inclusion I said it respectfully
a few months later I was told that my
name showed up on their website anyway I
contacted them I told them to take it
down they had the gall to still leave my
name yes I was a successful person in
this country so they thought they could
use my name and image along with people
like Mark Zuckerberg or others who they
had named Elon Musk that they had named
in the past
I wasn't going to let them get away with
that and so what I did is I said that
I'm going to stand up for what's right
I sued them I filed a lawsuit saying
that this was wrong
so he filed a lawsuit and the lawsuit
said hey take my name down apologize and
give me some money
and they obliged they were Dear Mr
ramaswamy we write on behalf of world
economic Forum in reference to the civil
action you filed we write to apologize
for this mistake The Forum nominated you
in 2021 as a young Global leader listed
you in several documents on the website
shortly afterward we learned you did not
wish to participate in this program we
took steps to remove you but
inadvertently inadvertently they say
fail to remove your name from all
Publications we acknowledge that this
continued inclusion on a young Global
leader document may have incorrectly
implied an association for that reason
we apologize for this unintentional
error sincerely the legal team and Vivek
has said that the monetary damages he
received he's going to donate to the
America First policy Institute or one of
these right-wing populist institutes
this is really good stuff uh why does it
matter one it helps for vex campaign and
it vindicates him on a charge that
really was unfair but the other reason
is it shows you something about about
the way the the elite liberal
establishment Works which is we always
think of it from the perspective of the
of the ladder climbers we always think
of it from the perspective of these
young ambitious probably in many cases
sociopathic young people who are seeking
association with these really
prestigious organizations these really
powerful shadowy organizations and uh so
they'll sell their souls out to go have
an association with the world economic
Forum or one of these groups that that's
one way that it works that that does
happen
but just as the the ambitious Young
would-be rulers or ambitious and eager
for association with these groups
so too the groups are eager for talent
and so with someone like Vivek he uh
is a Yale law school graduate he's very
successful right out the gate in a
Pharma company
he's making a lot of money he's shaking
things up he's an author he's going on
TV he had helps for the for at least for
the Liberals that he's Indian and you
know he's not just a straight white male
or anything like that and so he checks
all these boxes and they say well we
want that guy
we because not only we don't really care
if he if he leans on our brand Prestige
we want to lean on his reputational
Prestige so they recruit him in and
usually people will just go along with
it
in vivek's case he said wait hold on
what do I I get nothing out of this they
get they get something out of this I
don't want it because I don't I don't
agree with the world economic Forum but
it's a reminder because I think there's
a lot of theories that groups like wef
that there are these these totally
omnipotent powerful organizations that
you know rule the world and they don't
need anybody and everyone's just
suckling at the teeth of them no the the
the way that this works is a little bit
more complicated than that and they're
desperate for talent too they're
desperate to hold on to power and
sometimes you see chinks in the armor
like when they have to apologize for how
an association with them
has damaged the reputation
you see this in the Bud Light story you
see you've seen Shanks in the armor with
the liberal establishment quite a lot in
the last few weeks
now when you want to hire somebody
you shouldn't just list them as an
employee on your website without talking
to them you should of course check out
ZipRecruiter right now go to
ziprecruiter.com Knowles if you're
hiring you're probably dealing with
economic uncertainty now more than ever
it's important to hire the right people
faster and more efficiently to keep
overall costs down thankfully zip
recruiter is a hiring partner who's
focused on you and your needs from
pricing to technology everything that
zip recruiter does is for you and what
works best for you right now you can try
them for free at ziprecruiter.com
Knowles ZipRecruiter smart technology
identifies the best matches for your job
lets you invite candidates you really
want to apply to your job before other
businesses can snag them I love how
their pricing is super duper
straightforward you know what you pay
for before you post your job so you can
stick to your budget with no surprises
hire the very best with the help of a
partner that is all about you with
ZipRecruiter four out of five employers
who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality
candidate within day one just go to this
exclusive web address to try
ZipRecruiter for free ziprecruiter.com
Knowles that is ziprecruiter.com
ZipRecruiter the smartest way to hire
speaking of presidential candidates
Nikki Haley
not polling very well but she's still in
the race and she'll probably make it to
that first debate
Nikki Haley has a new ad out
identifying the enemy the villain in her
presidential campaign
Nikki Haley fought America's enemies at
the U.N and won China's dictators want
to cover the world in communist tyranny
Nikki Haley tough as Nails smart as a
whip unafraid to speak the truth
communist China won't just lose like the
Soviet Union before it communist China
will end up on the ash heap of History
strong leader for a strong American
SFA funding is responsible for the
content of this advertising
I really like Nikki Haley this is a very
bad ad it's a very bad ad because
it it looks like something out of the
80s
there would be virtually no difference
between the ad that Nikki's campaign is
running in 2023 and an ad that any
Republican would be running from the
1960s through the 1980s just replace
China with the Soviet Union and and he
or she even eludes that she goes this is
just like with the Soviet Union our
battle with China is just like the
battle with the Soviet Union but it's
not
it's not there was a real threat of
Soviet communism which had been
spreading everywhere coming in and
leading to the end of the world because
of this very close nuclear conflict that
we we nearly had that's not what's going
on in China
frankly the communism of China is is not
even close to the communism of the
Soviet Union
China though they still have the
Communist symbols and they'll sometimes
still invoke communism
they don't really have even a communist
country they've got their own thing
they've got their own weird thing that
allows for markets
that allows for some strong economic
growth that also clamps down on
social Liberties and it's just its own
thing and it's just different and even
beyond all of that
the vast majority of Americans the vast
majority of Republicans and
conservatives
don't view China as the biggest threat
to our way of life and our liberties and
our property and or families and our
traditions
we view liberalism as the big threat
is is communist China threatening to
lock you up for questioning the 2020
election is communist China threatening
to take away your job or your reputation
or your livelihood for violating the
covid lockdowns as communist China
trying to de-platform you from social
media for violating the the new woke
standards of whatever they pretend is
hate speech today no it's not it's the
libs it's the libs here
that threat is a lot closer to home does
does Xi Jinping call you a deplorable
irredeemable hillbilly hick who who
ought to just die out of the breeding
cycle
is that is it is it communist China
that's blowing open the southern border
or is it common it's not it's the lit
it's the liberal establishment here is
it communist China That's rigging our
elections no I don't think it is it's
the libs who are changing all the
election rules in the weeks and months
before the election in some cases
unconstitutionally
it's the libs and the reason that
I suspect whoever on the Nikki Haley
campaign put this head together did that
the reason why a lot of more
Centrist type GOP politicians are
leaning in on China communism is because
they don't want to take on liberalism
because they're still embracing many of
the premises of liberalism and they're
not recognizing what time it is the time
has changed it's not 1986 anymore
it's 2023.
politics is about applying Eternal
principles of Justice to changing
political circumstances the enemies are
different
the problems are the threats right now
are different
there's been
on the right a big shift really
beginning around the time of trump and
propelled in large part by Trump
and the shift is away from the right
saying we are the real liberals we're
the true we're the classical liberals
we're Libertarians we're I love liberal
we want to conserve liberalism to
something different saying actually
liberalism appears to have eroded our
whole society and America never viewed
itself as a liberal democracy until
really the middle of the 20th century we
always viewed ourselves as something a
little more classical a little more
traditional we viewed ourselves as a
Christian Nation and liberalism has
eroded National borders and liberalism
has kicked Christianity out of the
Public Square and and replaced
Christianity as the animating Spirit of
our civilization and as we've done that
back when we were a Christian Nation you
could teach the Bible in schools you
couldn't teach porn in schools today you
can in some cases must teach porn in
schools including elementary schools but
you're not the one book you're not
allowed to teach is the Bible and that's
no good and the result of that has been
the breakup of marriages the slaughter
of hundreds of thousands of babies a
drug crisis that is that is the worst in
American history flung open borders a
plummeting of trust in our election and
our our institutions on both sides of
the aisle and a population that is
literally dying because we can't replace
ourselves huh I don't blame communist
China for that wasn't even communism
never really took hold in America and
the people who were overt marxists I
wrote a whole book about the cultural
marxists the people who were marxists
after the end of Communism after the
fall of the Berlin Wall
they just kind of became part of the
liberal establishment this was true in
the former Soviet Bloc I was just in
Hungary and this was true in the west
also that's the problem here and I think
the the Republicans who know what time
it is who are going to jump in the polls
are the ones who say no it's it's not
just communist China it's
you can call it wokism you can call
political correctness you can call it
leftism or you can I think be even more
blunt about it and say that's liberalism
there's a problem with
liberalism
it's not it's not Xi Jinping who's
sending our communities Up in Smoke
right now you go to an American city
San Francisco especially good grief you
can barely walk into that City Chicago
DC Los Angeles New York crime is spiking
disorder is spreading
to the point now where people will just
regularly go into drug stores going to
convenience stores and then just go in
they'll have a bag or sometimes they'll
even have one of those gigantic like 60
gallon trash bins they'll drag them in
and they'll start emptying the shelves
put them in and because our our justice
system has been so perverted and
corrupted
the shop owners are not really allowed
to do anything about it they just have
to call the police the police don't come
it's too much crime and the people just
get away with it
and as a result of this
people can't walk down the street in
safety and the shops have to close up
shop
well there's a video just went viral of
some Thug some just ordinary Street Thug
walks in with a giant trash bin into a
convenience store and he just starts
emptying at the cigarettes you know so
it's it's just like in Les Miserables
trying to steal a loaf of bread to feed
your family no I don't know I don't
think this guy needs 200 packs of
cigarettes to you know survive until
another day well the shop owners
initially say
you can't do anything
man don't do that
but then no there we go
again
what looks like an immigrant comes over
is one of the guys holds holds the
robber down this immigrant comes over
and destroys beating him with a stick
it's a broom handle or something
[Music]
this might be the perfect beat down I've
ever seen and it's the perfect Beatdown
I've ever seen because the guy didn't
shoot him didn't kill him didn't stab
him he's not bleeding out or anything
and even the guy holding the stick he's
just not cracking the guy in the head
he's not giving him a concussion or
brain damage he's just he's just caning
him on his legs and on his torso nothing
is going to leave a really lasting
injury here but it is going to leave him
a lasting lesson I hope and why is this
video so shocking
these kind of robberies go on in cities
all over the country all the time why is
this one so shocking because our
political establishment says hey if you
s if you rob a shop you're gonna be let
off the hook you probably won't even get
a slap on the wrist if you loot during
the George Floyd riots for months Coast
to Coast yeah you'll just get your
charges dismissed but if you ever try to
stop a robber we're gonna throw the book
at you we're gonna charge you with
murder we're gonna send you to prison
for the rest of your life and so people
rightly who understand the way that our
two-tier justice system works they say
look I don't want any part of that steal
my stuff steal my cigarettes shut down
my shop I don't want to go to prison
because of this two-tiered perverted
justice system but then you see this guy
with the turbine the turbine is the
indication to me that this fella this
shop worker is an immigrant in New York
this guy I don't think he's totally
familiar
with
liberal decadent American culture the
culture that says robbers can do
whatever they want but Property Owners
can't so this guy looks at me says hold
on
get over here
and the guy filming he says no man you
can't do anything we gotta wait for the
cops to come you're not allowed no you
don't understand man you can't and the
guy with the turban he says uh no I
don't think so hold that guy and then so
the other the other person holds the guy
down he starts beating him with a stick
immigrants have much to teach us
you know the liberal service we have so
much to learn from the immigrants well I
finally agree
you're right
because in whatever country this guy's
from I prom I don't know what the
country is I don't know when he came
here
I promise you whatever country that guy
is from
they don't just let robbers come in and
take your cigarettes
there is
there is a natural impulse for justice
and if the cops aren't going to provide
it and if the prosecutors aren't going
to provide it and if the political
establishment's not going to provide it
then we're going to have to provide it
ourselves
that's what that guy that's the idea
that that guy is expressing by by
beating the robber very politely very uh
considerately I think with the stick
we have to do it we live in a political
order right now
that forgot about Justice and so the
issue runs a lot deeper than just
letting some criminals go in and steal
your your packs of cigarettes
a political order that says there is no
such thing as Justice there's no such
thing as right and wrong beyond what we
say it is a political order that says
that marriage isn't really what marriage
is political order that says
that men are not really men and women
are not really women a political order
that says that up is down and black is
white and
that perversion of Justice
is going to spread everywhere this is
why in New York under Giuliani probably
the best mayor in the history of the
city
New York they pursued broken windows
policing
broken windows policing said we're not
only going to go after the toughest not
only are we not going to let the
criminals off the hook
we're not only going to focus on the
most egregious crimes
we're going to focus on the most minor
crimes we're going to focus on a broken
window because when there's a broken
window in your neighborhood
that's going to attract criminals like
moths to a flame they're going to say oh
there's disorder here okay we can wreak
havoc you've gotta you've got to focus
on that this is why Giuliani went in he
didn't client clean up the nice
neighborhoods he cleaned up Times Square
which was a degenerate neighborhood he
turned Times Square into Disneyland and
he did it to send a message this
city is going to focus on Justice
and once again we were talking about
this with Justin Trudeau when disorder
seeps in it's like rayon in the air
you know it just it just
is it rayon or radon one of them is made
to make cheap T-shirts one of them is a
gas that poisons your family whichever
one it is it's in the air it poisons you
without you even recognizing it okay and
much like that
when one insists upon a principle of
Justice that's going to spread
throughout the air too and people are
going to behave a lot better it's it's
politics is not rocket science it's not
theoretical physics okay if you just
encourage good things and discourage bad
things you're going to get a better
Society
now
you need to give your son
and his values Fighting Chance with
Jeremy's back to college deals get up to
20 off select razor and men's care
bundles get Jeremy's shampoo body wash
and conditioner all paraben free sulfate
free woke free and made in the USA get
him a Precision five razor with welded
steel blades a sturdy tungsten handle
and flip back trimmer unlike your kids
radical professors Jeremy's aims to
groom his face
not his world view go to Jeremy's
racers.com for major deals on back to
college bundles today my favorite
comment yesterday is from Cox rocks 25
okay says Michael
Michael says guys be more masculine
Michael also says I love pumpkin spice
lattes drink white Claws and Barbie was
a great movie
Michael Now update also says my
followers are called cream puffs oh yes
they decided this in the in the chat
yesterday because I referred to the
crime and stuff handedly uh the you know
the Inner Circle not the Hawaii boy who
watched the show on YouTube but the
people who are members of daily wire.com
and so they've started to refer
themselves they said we're the creme de
la time but what does that make an
individual member of the Clem de La
Creme and someone
someone suggested cream puff and I
thought you know this is enough guys I
don't I listen to poetry I like Opera I
went to a particularly lavender
University I grew up in New York I grew
up in LA and the libs the libs look back
at my wayward youth my acting career
they never focus on the roles that I
played that were soldiers they never
focus on the roles I played that there
were football players they always find
the one gay guy that I played and they
say there he is he's a FANUC and now if
my listeners call themselves cream puffs
you know this is not going to help the
situation but hey
what can we do
what can we just can't prefer what can
we do uh speaking of odd identities
a Japanese fella
has has just spent fourteen thousand
dollars to make himself look like a
border collie he looks like Lassie
uh he's he spent it on a costume
mercifully this was not a a very
extensive hair plug surgery or any other
cosmetic surgery it's just it's a
costume it's very convincing costume
uh he he goes by the name Toco
and he just shared a video of him
stepping out in public for the first
time rolling around in the park in front
of children dressed up as a dog
uh he has 42 000 subscribers on YouTube
and this is not just a prank or
something which would be kind of funny
he he sincerely wants to be an animal
that's what he says on the channel and
and then
here's what else he says he says do you
remember your dreams from when you were
little
you want to be a hero or a wizard I
remember writing in my grade school
graduation book that I wanted to be a
dog and walk around outside
yeah yeah sure
first of all in his defense
his costume is much more persuasive than
so he's done better there than a lot of
confused people
but this is very sad
and
what's saddest about it is he seems to
be somewhat conscious of the of the
problem here you see that he says the
problem he says do you remember your
dreams from when you were little
well I'm just doing that as an adult
that's the problem and I think that's
what's underlying a lot of the
pathologies in our society not just
people having imaginary identities
but
the people who refuse to grow up
the people who they get married but they
don't they don't want to really get
married you know they want to keep their
lives mostly separate they don't want to
change their name they don't want to get
a shared bank account they don't want to
change any aspect of their lives it's
it's I guess it's technically a marriage
but it's not it's still people holding
on to their individualism
or they get married but they don't want
to have kids even if they can't have
kids they don't want to have kids they
don't want to or let's say they don't
want to get married marriage rates have
plummeted or they don't want to be in a
serious relationship or they don't want
to
buy a house or they don't want to
commit relate to anything which is a
major problem for the millennial
generation we'll see how it affects the
older Zoomers
it's all back to this problem that the
Border Collie Man is identifying which
is
say well when I was a little kid
I I didn't want to do those things when
I was a little kid I wanted to do X Y
and Z and so I'm just going to keep
doing X Y and Z for the rest of my life
it's very sad this ties in with the
Barbie movie actually it's one of the
things I really liked about the Barbie
movie yeah I won't talk about the Barbie
movie too much but
the Barbie movie
plot begins
because Barbie is stuck in this
perpetual
pointless present
in Barbie land at the beginning of the
movie every day is exactly the same wake
up go to the beach haha they do Beach
you know they kind of walk around the
beach then there's a party at Barbie's
house and they all go to the party but
then the boys have to go away because
it's girls night and then they just and
they do the exact same thing every day
and the movies plot really begins when
Barbie says wait a second you guys ever
think about death
you ever think about time you ever think
about aging and changing and and that's
the the driving theme throughout the
movie
growing up and what it means not just
for an individual but even passing on
to the Next Generation and how a society
grows up and we've stopped that and it's
no wonder that as we've stopped the
process of individual maturation as
we've stopped uh looking at and admiring
older people and shifted our Focus as a
society to now we say we need to learn
from the children children know
everything we need to listen to them
about everything we need to trust
everything that they say we have to
assume that they have perfect faculties
of Reason well Grandma she doesn't know
what she's talking about throw her in a
home kill her through euthanasia old
people don't old people are dumb and
stupid and racist probably and they
don't matter and they should just die
but young little children they know
everything that's that bizarre inversion
of society
has led to a society that is dying
because it won't grow up
like this guy will grow up it's not it's
not bad that when he was five years old
he said I want to be a doggy that's kind
of cute it's childlike
but when an adult says that it's
childish and it's very sad and it's
destructive and it will harm him and the
rest of society
is it real dark side to this we can we
can make jokes about and we can't even
think it's kind of funny if I walk
through the park and I saw some dude in
a fifteen thousand dollar fourteen
thousand dollar border collie suit I'd
probably get a kick out of it probably
take a picture and say oh hey you know
hey Lassie but then the flip side of it
is when
it affects people in a deeper level
like in this story that I can't talk
about on YouTube
uh a Canadian
[Music]
so maybe we need
an alternative an alternative to
liberalism how about that well we'll get
into maybe some of those alternatives on
theology Thursday baby and we have
one of my very best friends George
farmer coming on the show you might know
him as Mr Candace Owens
I know him as
the great Trad Catholic king of
Nashville Tennessee the rest of the show
continues now you do not want to miss it
become a member use code Knowles Canada
W Alias at check out for two months free
on all annual plans
[Music]